hello and welcome back to the shaky
silent show so in this video I thought I
would show a few some key lessons that
I've learned from the week one of my PhD
so far so a few weeks ago I posted a
video on how I was preparing for my PhD
well I have officially started the
journey and have learnt quite locked
mainly unrelated to my main project so
far that I knew is really useful
information so I have decided to make a
video to share these tips that I've
gained so that you watching can benefit
the kind of also from my own benefit
since I feel like I'm like Lucifer Gatz
most these important lessons that I've
learnt so far
so I very broadly split these lessons
and the two categories getting organized
and then adding to the apps that I
mentioned about in the previous video
and the apps I've already been using so
firstly getting organized very fake
title I know so in the previous video
that I made I think I spoke about the
importance of labeling and making sure
you could keep track of my different
samples and staying on top of things but
this first week has introduced me to new
concepts that I think also going to be
really important and I didn't even think
about when I made the first video say
those kinds under the umbrella of
strategic planning and so this includes
planning of the experiments will design
the questions you're trying to address
the aims hypothesis and the experiments
itself and then once you've got the
experiments in mind to check do I have
all the bridges that I needs are these
rages that I can get available to myself
if I don't have them and then can I pick
the equipment that I'm going to use and
do all of this before you just jump into
the experiment so a lot of things tips
has come from this nature a few art
school which I actually really highly
recommend that you read it and it's
quite funny but also quite serious and I
did a little bit scary and but it just
raises some really important points and
I'll try in some ways the majority of
these main points in this video but yeah
she's definitely read it I recommend and
so just for example one of the first
points it makes is that we are often
thought as scientists to be asking the
right question but to be able to ask the
right question we also need to be
getting high quality data that actually
answers the question and that is also
important and should be taken into
account
the key thing being do you trust your
data and so if you were unsure of this
and how to go about asking the right
question and setting up your experiments
correctly the key other lessons I've
learnt is to be friendly smile and make
friends of people who you're working
with although it's often thought that
scientists are locked up away from the
community that just isn't the case and
we are a community of their own we work
together as teams we collaborate but
also you should be suspect of your peers
do you trust them say one clip that I
picked up from this nature of you at
school is in God be trust everybody else
must show you controls and this kind of
links to my next points about risk
assessment and risk assessment in terms
of how much we can trust the various
elements of are certain experiments and
given circumstance and so it's like if
something's gone wrong is it because
there's something wrong with the
reagents the proscar isn't the right
preschool it's energy do you believe
that if you add this for 18 and this
event happens is that the case should
she is that the right sound line that
you can give it and should you choke yes
probably probably good idea that's what
I've learned
so it's more about being cautious than
to just go around judging everyone I'm
not believing anyone and to be aware of
it and so as as create States it's true
70 percent but probably not exactly of
70 percent but a decent proportion of
how well your experiment goes depends on
how well you plan it and how boy you
planets also comes under this idea of
risk assessment and how you know time is
precious and if you can take the time to
really carefully write down experimental
details check you've got reactions check
you have got the right sound line for
example because see if you see much time
later on when something does go wrong so
now I'm sort of more data collection
side of things a key lesson I've learned
is the importance of having tidy data
and so one of the key takeaway messages
that we were taught about is the idea of
separating your mess
data from your data and creating data
files and inputting your data because it
makes it easier to work with and say
metadata refers to the sorts of data
that describes and gives information
about other data so this could be like
the name of your cell line and
additional information such as where the
cell line came from what mutations are
present stuff like that okay really
it depends on what the theater is of
course and so by separating your
metadata from your data you avoid the
use of so called white data and instead
creates probably more tables but longer
tables that are thinner and these tables
are easier to then import into other
applications to analyze your data and so
that's the parks or SAS benefit well the
reason why you should want to do this
and so I don't really know why I put
this in the video again but yeah this is
the key difference between what metadata
and data is so theta is your actual
experimental values so I have already
slightly mentioned this but how and why
is separating this mess data from data
are so important for data input well
just before I answer this question as
we've now moved on to adding to the apps
which I kind of the apps I speak about
in the previous video I wanted to
introduce you to an app that I found
pretty useful so far and it's
coordination so notion is another
note-taking project management app which
the producers described as the
all-in-one workspace so think of it like
Evan a trail a OneNote combines and so
far I've I've even used nation to make
the script for this video
yep that's right I actually do try and
plan what I'm going to say pre-recorded
well sometimes but I am very much an
office at using nature and so far so if
you once have a better introduction to
nation from a pro notion user then check
out this video by Thomas Frank where he
shows you how he's is it for his own
projects and I think that nation could
just be a really cool and good tool for
organizing a PhD Nate's a different
projects all sleep as my life and my
other self it's just and it syncs
between different devices so if I have
not reached like a limited
number of computers of the faces I can
have it on not that I have that many
anyway but yeah Isis been pretty cool so
I suggest you talk about but one app
that I did mention last time was our
studio so one of the introduction
sessions that I had was a brief entry to
find cymatics
and one thing that is true for myself
but what many other people also said is
that they have doubled in our so far in
that right
and that wasn't scripted but it's true
my eyes have now been open to much more
for our can actually D and so already
knew about the different packages that
come along with our studio such as
ggplot2 which I have used for making
gorgeous figures but there is this thing
called tidy first and look like I don't
really know its full potential yet but
apparently now is a good time and
somehow it works I'm familiar with using
for coding in our because it's just a
really useful way to analyze your data
and it's you can also you have this
thing called shiny apps and on lockdown
even for making PDFs or your are scripts
so I'm sorry in instructions what are it
stays on so it is effectively a
programming software that enables you to
live in your data and graphs to analyses
from your thoughts and probably much
more because I am so definitely a novice
and using our but we shall fair not and
look there's my script because there is
a free online introduction to our and
how to use it and so I will be slowly
making my way through this and from what
I've read so far it actually ties back
into what I was saying earlier about
having tidy data and so I quite like
this flow charts where they display and
emphasize the importance and
understanding your data and that many
how how many times you came around the
sleep you need to do the understanding
before you try to report and communicate
your results and so another app which oh
if it really counts and up and that can
also help you tied your data is called
open refine and there's something
literally never come across before and
so I yeah I can't really see much so I
fell in looks into it myself but it's a
way that you can kind of merge and like
modify your data sets to get it from
that wide data set suppose something
about into those long and thin data sets
which you can then what
easily important to things like ah and
so another software I call themself I
know that I've been introduced to that
I'd never heard of before in Slab
archives which is a kind of one platform
for having an online e lab book and so
it's more than just tracking your daily
lab life you can add photos you can add
protocols and you can also share them
with people and do much more of it again
I haven't really looked into it but I
think it could be useful so you should
check out and so the likelihood is is
that I forgotten something but for one
week I think I've been witness to many
key taking messages to keep on the top
of my mind throughout my PhD and Beyond
and the studium of this video was to
subscribe this advice so I hope that you
have found some of this useful and
definitely check out that nature a few
people and yeah I just hope this was
valuable information thanks for
listening